Yesterday on the show, I told you that coronavirus
vaccine manufacturers, Pfizer and Moderna
rightly turned down an invitation from Donald
Trump to go to this propaganda event at the
White House, which they called the vaccine
summit.
And it is it's a really good thing that Pfizer
and Moderna did turn that down because it
was completely humiliating and embarrassing.
And Donald Trump simply could not contain
himself once again, blurting out seemingly
uncontrollably that he won when he took questions,
having nothing whatever to do with vaccination.
So let's go through this and you will quickly
notice that Donald Trump, although he likely
realizes that Joe Biden will be president
on January 20th, he still can't accept that
he simply lost.
And this is exactly the behavior we would
predict from narcissists like Donald Trump.
This is exactly what they would struggle with.
So we'll start with the wackiest moment, which
is when Donald Trump was confronted with the
reality that the next administration, Joe
Biden's administration, they will be overseeing
most of the vaccine distribution.
And wouldn't it make sense to involve them
in this discussion?
And Trump just can't help himself.
And he blurts out, he won.
You know, he won.
Check it out.
And he sort of tries to stay on track, but
he falls apart with lies about stealing the
election.
Just a humiliating answer.
The next administration will be the one ultimately
that implements a lot of the distribution
of this vaccine and will oversee the future
of the way Operation Works goes forward.
Why not include members of the Obama transition
team as part of this summit they are hosting
today, where we're going to have to see who
the next administration is because we won
and those swing states and there was terrible
things that went on.
So we're going to have to see who the next
administration is.
But whichever the next administration is will
really benefit by what we've been able to
do with this incredible science.
The doctors, all of the people that came up,
the lab technicians, the work, the work that's
been done is incredible.
And it will be incredible for the next administration
and hopefully the next administration will
be the Trump administration because you can't
steal hundreds of thousands of votes.
You can't have fraud and deception and all
of the things that they did and then slightly
win a swing state.
And you just have to look at the numbers,
look at what's been on tape, look at all the
corruption and we'll see.
You can't win an election like that.
So hopefully the next administration will
be the Trump administration, a continuation
which has led us to the highest stock markets
we've ever had, the best employment numbers
we've ever had.
A rebuilt military, if you look at the tax
reductions, are the greatest in history.
The regulation reductions, the greatest in
history.
It leads us to space force, which nobody thought
was possible.
All of the things we've done and we were rewarded
with a victory.
Now let's see whether or not somebody has
the courage, whether it's a legislator or
legislatures or whether it's a justice of
the Supreme Court or a number of justices
of the Supreme Court.
Let's see if they have the courage to do what
everybody in this country knows is right.
I received almost 75 million votes, the highest
number of votes in the history of our country
for a sitting president.
So that's two minutes of coocoo off the wall
stuff.
I'm not going to go through all of it, but
as you can see, Donald Trump cannot accept
his loss.
He still is telling lies after lies, after
lies about the election.
Trump then falsely claimed plainly that it
would take five to six years to make a vaccine
normally were it not for Trump, thanks to
Operation Warp Speed.
He did it in nine months.
And then later he says, you know, without
operation warp speed, it could take infinity
to make a vaccine before Operation Warp Speed.
The typical timeframe for development that
approval, as you know, could be infinity.
Now, as I've told you before, but it bears
repeating the reason that the Pfizer, Moderna
and AstraZeneca, Oxford vaccines were developed
quickly, both in and out of the US, understand
that the timeline was identical in and out
of the U.S., regardless of operation warp
speed.
Is it a different type of vaccine?
This it's a vaccine that works on an MRN platform
rather than a live or weakened virus.
It has nothing to do with Trump.
It's science.
It's a type of vaccine that's faster to develop.
I mentioned yesterday that Donald Trump failed
to secure possibly one hundred million doses
of the vaccine offered to him by Pfizer in
late summer.
We're going to talk about this more later.
But now Donald Trump is trying to hide this
by talking about an executive order.
Listen to this.
We're working with the world.
We have great companies and we're working
with the world.
In just a few minutes, I'll sign an executive
order to ensure that the United.
States government prioritizes the getting
out of the vaccine to American citizens before
sending it to other nations, now, if necessary
at all, you will invoke the Defense Production
Act.
So what Trump is doing here, because he failed
to simply say, yes, give us the doses, he
now realizes there's going to be a supply
issue.
Since Pfizer sold the doses, Trump turned
down to other countries.
So Trump has come up with an executive order
he's going to sign.
It's not clear at all that the executive order
will do a damn thing.
It's not clear how it would be enforced.
It's not clear who would enforce it.
It's not clear how it gets us a single additional
dose.
Trump failed again, but he has this executive
order idea, which we'll talk about more later.
And then Trump, I guess, struggling with language
and physics, saying cases will soon skyrocket
downwards.
Listen to that.
The numbers should skyrocket downward.
I guess he means cases will soon burrow down
deep into the ground.
Very, very low.
Strange language to be using.
And then Trump actually took some questions.
He was asked about, we have holidays upcoming.
We how do you want people to be safe?
Vaccines won't be widely rolled out until
next year.
And Trump seems to refer to approaching herd
immunity because of what he claims are 15
percent of people who got the virus and recovered.
It's a very weird moment.
I'm wondering what your message to the American
people, given all of the increase in cases
right now about what they should do over Christmas
and parts of the bureaucracy as this virus
does get worse?
Well, CDC puts out their guidelines and the
very important guidelines.
But I think this I think that the vaccine
was our goal.
That was number one, because that was the
way it was the way it ends.
Plus, you do have an immunity.
You develop immunity over a period of time.
And I hear we're close to 15 percent.
I'm hearing that.
And that is terrific.
That's a very powerful vaccine in itself.
So the president seems to be saying there
15 percent of the country already got the
virus and they've recovered.
So they're immune.
So we have 15 percent immunity right now.
This is a dangerous claim for a few reasons.
No.
One, officially, we've only had 15 and a half
million cases, minus nearly 300000 that died,
meaning we have about fifteen point two million
people we know about who either have recovered
or have the virus now, most of whom will survive.
That's under five percent of the population.
When Trump says 15 percent have had it been
recovered, it's possible that for every case
we know about, there's two point something
more that we don't know about.
That would mean, you know, about 50 million
people have had the virus.
It could be a stretch.
We don't know.
But the really dangerous part is we don't
know whether every recovered patient is equally
immune or how long that natural immunity lasts.
It's possible that most of those light or
asymptomatic cases may not have the same immunity
that somebody who had symptoms and a more
serious case and recovered does.
We just don't know.
So, as usual, Trump is clueless and he's erring
rather than on the side of caution, he's erring
on the side of belligerence.
Later, Trump was asked why the White House
is holding in person parties with hundreds
of people violating the CDC guidelines.
And Trump said, well, listen, these are Christmas
parties he's talking to.
Officials here in this room have encouraged
Americans not to travel this holiday season,
not to go to large gatherings across the street.
You've been holding holiday parties with hundreds
of people, many not wearing masks.
Why are you bottling a different behavior
to the American people than what you're trying
to tell?
Well, their Christmas parties and frankly,
we've reduced the number very substantially,
as you know.
And I see a lot of people at the parties wearing
masks.
I mean, I would say that I look out at the
audience, at those parties who we have a lot
of people wearing masks, and I think that's
a good thing.
Oh, right.
A Christmas party.
If it's Christmas, then I guess you're protected
somehow.
It's different then, you know, Hanukkah party
or Super Bowl party.
That's different.
These are Christmas parties, after all.
They're indoor events with literally hundreds
of people.
And then lastly here, Trump calls for judges
and Republican legislators to have what he
calls the courage to help him overthrow the
election results.
Unable to accept what has taken place here,
I received almost 75 million votes, the highest
number of votes in the history of our country.
For a sitting president, 12 million more than
the 63 million we received four years ago.
President Obama received three million less
in his second term, and he won easily.
I received 12 million more, which, by the
way, is a record 12 million more.
They say that when the numbers came out and
the numbers came through, machines and all
of those ballots were taken away and added,
all you have to do is turn on your local television
set and you'll see what happened.
So another embarrassing, shameful, destructive
Q&A session for Donald Trump.
And as we continue to move towards the end
of the year, holiday, Christmas, Hanukkah
starting very soon, very much looking forward
to it.
We are increasingly hearing rumors that Donald
Trump is sort of going to just go to Florida
and maybe never come back to Washington, D.C.
He'll just kind of disappear.
He may never concede.
He may not be at the inauguration.
He may just kind of be gone and then maybe
start campaigning for 2024.
Still a question mark, but I don't anticipate
too many more of these Q&A sessions.
Let's now focus in on this vaccine executive
order that I mentioned earlier.